[Music]
[Applause]
hello welcome to channel Awesome's orbit
report your source for entertainment
news around the world Ayanna and Heather
are out this week so you are joined by
the wonderful Malcolm ray and Tamra
chambers equally wonderful thank you
this is your news for August 21st 2017
and here we go oh my god oh my god
Disney's making moves
Disney is going to start like releasing
you know remakes and whatnot but I think
like the biggest franchise that they've
got going for themselves right now that
Marvel is Star Wars ah yeah it's crazy
like right now it's all speculation
right but there's talks of an obi-wan
solo movie like it's just hard to say
without saying like Thank You obi-wan
solo movie version is like kiss of a
standalone movie about obi-wan and it's
like you said all speculations so far
but they would be so exciting if we
could get you and McGregor in on it and
can't like a like a lot what would you
want to see out of this movies well I
mean like you know the initial thought
would be like I want you know an origin
story but then you think about it and
it's kind of like well we're kind of
dipping into the prequel territory
I know Disney wants to tackle that
touchy yeah I know some of you are
prequel fans but I mean I mean so maybe
there's not much to really talk about no
I guess I just like Star Wars content in
general but I think it would be really
exciting to see a little bit of the
training um with gligar qui gonn would
be really exciting um but yeah there's
and you don't really want to delve too
much into the 1 2 into it right I mean I
mean I get me interesting to see if
there was like some kind of ulterior
motive with Jar Darby and like one thing
I kind of like one
this is a prequel welcome guys so it's
because of that fan theory that fan
theory specifically is what made me kind
of want Jar Jar Binks the biggest thing
but yeah nobody wants them I'm excited
for the possible obi-wan movie I would
love though to see a Disney cake the
Star Wars franchise into a direction of
like a newer film like it was a newer
character bring in some fresh stuff like
different worlds and genres in the Star
Wars universe I think would be so
exciting to see see their take on it
yeah I don't know if it would
necessarily be like a sequel because I
mean he's a force ghost now so it's not
like he's gonna be like finn used before
you can use your medical or in count
high enough you know why not like so I
think the only area like that little gap
between three and four there's like a
19-year gap where he was looking over
Luke and and Leia god I almost said Pat
man like no AIDS
oh yeah he's looking over Luke and Leia
and you know he's protecting them making
sure that they're safe from the Empire
because you know they're being you know
sought after all the dead iron good and
if if they got you McGregor it would be
the perfect age range for him so that'd
be really exciting her also being said
that speculated I guess that a Steven
Daldry is going to be the director and
he has directed Billy Elliot Extremely
Loud and Incredibly Close
a couple other movies that I also
haven't seen and I think it's an
interesting choice he does more drama it
wasn't like him not so much sci-fi so
that's a interesting right way to go so
I mean he would be directing more so the
actors and the emotion in that I like it
yeah we'll see where I go um then
defenders just came out on Netflix which
is like Netflix version of The Avengers
and I haven't checked it out yet but
it's got a 7080 percent on Rotten
Tomatoes so far which will see if I goes
up or down right I mean it's all dark
yeah I mean we got Jessica Jones with
cage
we got daredevil but who knows like you
can make up for it in defenders
you know yeah the whole team in order to
have defender yeah I'd seem like they're
gonna have a really good chemistry I'm
very excited to check that out yeah so
we'll see how that goes I mean my
friends are raving about it
agents of shield has been really good I
hear I had it like I lost track of it
but it's really good oh yeah it's a cool
off center Marvel and also just a cool
set for streaming to have this high of a
caliber of show and series of shows so
that's really funny yeah up next we're
going to be talking about Dragon Ball
super now I know not everybody follows
Dragon Ball like myself and Walter but I
am a really big fan and the manga in
Japan has caught up with the anime and
the development has come up where vegeta
has you know decided to challenge
beerus in a fight and you get to see
like the gap in power is still there and
the power scaling in Dragon Ball super
as we just really I'm like what does
this mean like why can they not you know
keep up like I don't know but like Super
Saiyan blue vegeta beerus still can't
touch them and it's got everybody kind
of disappointed like are they getting
any closer the only thing I know about
Dragon Ball is that trunks is an
adorable name yeah you'll never get not
name is what breathes like it's like an
adorable little cat that I really love
that's great well right I'll have to
watch the series you gotta watch it your
grandfather actually has a little black
cat that rests on the shoulder is a
scientist he's working the cats are
sitting there I don't know if you guys
know if I really like cats perfect
Oh PlayStation just announced that they
are beta testing their 5.0 edition
they're saying that it's going to
feature an overhauled family management
system and various other enhancements
which I have no idea what that means I'm
very excited for a new console yeah you
know like it's good that they're making
advancement but I feel like they there's
still so much more to develop on the ps2
I want to see the VR come on Bryn is a
VR junkie just came out yeah like the PS
like I still even have to ps4 like I've
been playing the ps4 at friends places
like right
want to get food go make the plunge
right I think I'll make the puns but
then oh yes I reckon developments like
ya know we're getting to the point of
like Apple phones yeah can't keep up
yeah yeah I I am really excited about
the way that VR is developing I really
want that VR fallout yeah I tried the
oculus and Ike
I lost my help me find my I
can't see without my shampoo thank you
I just want a video of like you get the
video of you doing - lets play and
Malcolm you're doing it and then
somebody's doing a behind-the-scenes but
there's Malcolm that's what I want
that's the content I signed up for
that's what I want
watch me stumble around a room down it's
kind of Daniels I can do that no problem
anyway speaking of video games
overwatch recently got two new modes -
deathmatch mode and it's spark live
debate like not everybody is really
feeling it because overwatch is a very
tactical game it involves teamwork and
deathmatch modes are you know whoever
reaches the certain number of kills
first is the winner but that is really
imbalanced especially in the
free-for-all death mode because it's
just you know individual characters
fighting each other and whoever reaches
you know I think it's like 30 kills
first they're the winner ah yeah and
it's like it's really imbalanced because
it's more so it's biased in favor to the
speedier characters you know like Genji
doom fist Sombra you know they're gonna
be skating around like just you know
punching and you know evading like
attacks in sombre she can go invisible
so it's like me so unfinished like a
Super Smash Brothers kind of like dual
game is a like a first-person shooter
you know but yeah yeah a missing you oh
yeah yeah it's like you know hover
recession yeah whoever reaches the you
know highest number of kills gotcha okay
whoever hits the golden number first
they're the winner I just got over
watching very excited to check it out
but that nothing very unfair
yeah a big slow character is unable so
it's good thing yeah
like you know Ryan Hart's got this
gigantic shield he's meant for defense
like you know these character supposed
to be used in tandem with each other so
you know imagine trying to use a pre pro
deathmatch he's just using his shield
well he's just getting like I'm slotted
by it's like all these other guys and I
mean it makes up for though the other
the other mode is team deathmatch where
the team dynamic still comes into play
which is better overwatch is more of a
team based game right and so you know
you still got that balanced aspect to it
but well you'll have to come over and
play on my team sure you guys can check
me out playing that game on twitch a
Tamra is playing and also on Twitter at
Tamra L chambers yes and you can find me
at Twitter as well
Malcolm the Ray that's invoice and stuff
which is the best Ayanna and Heather
we'll be back next week and you guys can
catch them at Wizard World make sure to
check out social media to see when and
where that need up is going to be and we
will see you next week
[Applause]
you